good morning John it's Wednesday I'm in
bed because I feel really bad yesterday
I felt fine at 8 o'clock and then by 9
o'clock I had 101 degree fever and a
sore throat and a sinus headache and all
of my skin hurt to touch so I felt like
that having anything touch me then I
wanted to go to bed so I did and then I
woke up about 25 different times because
I was having the same dream over and
over again about having to build a
satellite out of LEGO pieces with an
incompetent team of jerks who didn't
know how to build a satellite it was
really embarrassing that our satellite
was so bad and I had that dream all
night long the same dream over and over
again and I really didn't like it and I
had to pee a lot
I did get my computer so that I could be
awake and do things while in bed I love
that you can do that nowadays you can
totally be a productive citizen without
ever having to leave your bed
I watched episodes of Tiny Toon
Adventures which I love that show so I
came to have the fun with Yakko Wakko
and dot and bub Babs and Buster bunny
and pinky in the brain and as is a
stuffed animal that I was cuddling with
it why is it a strike when you missed
the ball and baseball why isn't it you
strike like if I strike you you don't
say I struck you if I missed the make
any sense and I also spent some time
exploring your pants and I found some of
my favorite threads in the history of
all forums ever like this one that you
can click in the doobly-doo about how
sciency people to blow minds
it's great and then this one there was a
thread for people from Palestine and
people from Israel and then the people
in those and the thread decided that
they should collaborate and be one
thread Middle East peace in your pants I
also really like this one which people
talk about
how they became nerdfighters everybody
finds these videos a different way and
there's a million billion ways to do it
and there's one person for every way to
do it if there's a million billion of
you I sometimes I feel like we've been
on fair to the giraffe's John I think
that we can make it up to them
additionally I have some great news if
you live in Seattle or Portland I'm
going to be in Seattle or Portland next
month March II times and I don't know
exactly when but I'll put the
information in the describe Boop
I'm gonna go to bed John I'll see you on
Friday